so glad we could bring this project to
this neighborhood so rich history I grew
up in a neighborhood like this oh yeah
like this all right welcome to mama
sugar banks y'all ready dog yeah can I
have a chicken-fried steak with gravy
and a cola I will have the baked beef
short ribs with collard greens and throw
down some that cornbread all right thank
you know what hold up a second I'm also
going to have some of them collard
greens and cornbread as well but hook a
brother up with some of them hot all
right
why am I trying to front scratch all
that give me some okra and some fried
red snapper and girl you know I want
some chitlins all right
y'all got ham hocks well that's what I
want I want to play the ham hocks
deep-fried blackened and served on a bed
of mustard greens pig feet I want some
pig feet and four pounds of grits Oh
ain't no what else give me a little
Dixie cup full of lard all right I just
remember what I want a bowl of
mosquitoes
none of them tiny ones either give me
them big mother to find down at the
swamps sister could you please hook a
brother up with a rusty bucket full of
fish heads wrapped and razor wire dunk
your teeth dunk your teeth straight out
a donkey's mouth
you know what any animal tooth will do I
want you to stick it in some honey blaze
fry with fat back and serve it in an old
tin coffee can forget everything I said
up to this point right now bring me some
dandelion greens a cow hip and a dog
face wrap that whole mess in an old
Ebony magazine and serve it to me in a
shoebox okay I want a platter of stork
ankles an old cellar door a possum spine
and a human foot
you want a human foot mm-hmm I got just
one question for y'all you want gravy on
that cellar door oh yeah oh yeah yeah
you got a great builder yeah something
going without gravy it's not food
[Music]